in may 2019 police launched operation
marksman an investigation into an
alleged gang of child abusers in hull
they told us when we first got involved
the investigation they were not going to
stop until they were all behind bars
and now two years later they're all
walking free
already we've spoken to two alleged
victims three others gave a supporting
testimony like most rape cases this
investigation folded without charges but
did the police miss a crucial witness
[Music]
i ended up in hull
because of a
gang of individuals
who
were trafficking me for sexual
exploitation
the young woman we'll call kate hasn't
been interviewed by police in this
investigation yet her testimony seems
significant what do you remember about
hull which sort of places did you go to
the place i remember most is hustle for
sure
but i just remember being back of cars
just being
raped and
is somewhere other girls mention kate
also names some of the same individuals
if she was trafficked into the city her
story would add another dimension to
this case implying a larger scale
network
the only way i can describe it is like
different hubs
so
you would have like a local group
who run an area
but then like they're networked in
with other areas and then what they
would do is swap girls
and then you'd be that groups for say
the night or a couple of days and then
you go back to yours
but there were like common people
throughout them all
in previous reports we've told you about
two young women one we called sarah and
another anna who were at the center of
operation marksman another young woman
says after she went to the police she
was threatened and this photo posted on
snapchat of a knife and a gun
other evidence includes diaries
documenting abuse a school log where a
teacher makes hundreds of entries about
exploitation concerns photos that
support claims a girl was beaten and
strangled and a screenshot of a text
where a schoolgirl is told that if she
doesn't come for sex with the men they
will kill her and bury her near the
water
if we've got an image if it depicts a
bruise
um a
copy of a text message
that is a standalone piece of evidence
we then need to look at what evidence
around that supports
that so we can say without a shadow of a
doubt when we get to court that that
bruise has been caused by this person in
this circumstances
homicide police say they've made 34
arrests and seized 150 devices and
didn't find supporting evidence but
admit that criminals can have multiple
phones and that with snapchat their
messages disappear
do you accept that maybe the digital
evidence just isn't going to exist
because it's done on snapchat
that cost is that you know that is a
possibility that's always going to be
there we if we can't see it we can't
prove it
so then what i'm saying is if you've got
the school reports you've got the
teacher saying well i saw the text
you've got the girl showing you the
strangulation marks aren't you going
well we haven't got a digital evidence
well hang on a second why don't we just
test this in court
getting something to call as i'm sure
you're aware
is
you know it's not easy we've got to get
through the evidential threshold so have
we done every line of inquiry we can yes
i'm confident we have had
our hydrant have been interviewers
they are confident with the
investigation they've done they've
stated we've followed best practice have
you spoken to any other women who've
been trafficked
into hull
from outside of hull
it's not relevant
i don't believe so because we're talking
i thought you were talking about the ins
and outs of marksman if anyone was
brought into hull and abused by the same
people that wouldn't fall into the
inquiry
police later clarified that would form
part of their investigation if it
happened in the same time frame and
locations and we've given them kate's
details but she is mistrustful having
spoken to other police forces about
sexual abuse in other areas
i think
i think i'd need some reassurances
before i spoke to any police again
that i wouldn't be palmed off as a liar
or that i'm insane or that i'm a
prostitute
i think they've got a lot of work to do
to gain trust back
in grooming cases evidence can be
particularly conflicting texts from
victims to suspect might look complicit
making the evidence threshold harder to
cross
psychotherapist joe wagstaff works with
groomed young women including one of our
victims
you've listened to those stories what do
you think
as to whether i believe them i
absolutely believe them
you know to sit with somebody
who
describes that level of abuse
um
[Music]
and you can you can feel that pain the
hurt
the shame the blame the guilt i think
the more cases that are left without
with no further action
um
it will prevent young people from coming
forward because what's the point
exploitation expert jim gamble who
helped us examine this evidence doesn't
blame frontline police but says they're
under-resourced
i think if we're looking at how do we
really make a difference from a criminal
justice point of view
that is that we do treat this as
seriously as we treat terrorism that is
that we actually release surveillance
resources to collect pattern of life on
these individuals that we use technical
surveillance so we can monitor where
they are and who they're talking to this
is organized you know industrial level
rape how did you feel you know when this
sort of came to an end and you had to
say that guys we've exhausted all our
lines inquiry
disappointed upset
um
disappointing for the girls
you know that this is their this has
been there they've lived through some
horrific offences
anna and sarah believe their evidence
should be enough
they said unless more girls come forward
they can't take it to court
so basically more girls to be abused
so they can put the men in prison
i know if i stood up in a court of law
and i can say this one million percent
if i told my story my full full story to
a court of law
they'd believe me
evidence or no evidence they would
believe me because it's not something
you can just make up
the biggest concern for the people of
hull is that if what they say is true
it could still be happening
which is why sky news will continue to
follow this story wherever it takes us
next
jason farrell sky news